even our cereal companies are
gaslighting us these days
yes our breakfast cereal companies are
gaslighting us
if you missed this yesterday you missed
the most enjoyable thing on the entire
internet
a guy with a blue checkmark named jensen
carp
discovered shrimp tails
in his cereal in his cinnamon toast
crunch
and it's gross and you can see the
shrimp tails are covered up
covered up in cinnamon sugar he tweets
out
um cinnamon toast crunch he tags them
why are there shrimp tails in my cereal
this is not a bit
cinnamon toast crunch responds and says
we're sorry to see what you found
we would like to report this to our
quality team and replace the box
can you please send us a dm to collect
more details thank you
they want to replace the box so this guy
jensen corp responds and says guys
i'm not sure i'm ready for another box i
don't finding like gross shrimp tails in
my cereal i don't
another box is the last thing i want
cinnamon toast crunch response says we
understand your concern
we promise you that our team will look
into this and get to the bottom of it
but in the meantime we want to do
everything we can to make this right we
need further details
then they come back and he keeps joking
with them they come back and say after
further examination with our team that
closely examined the image
it appears to be an accumulation of the
cinnamon sugar that sometimes can occur
when ingredients aren't thoroughly
blended
we assure you that there is no
possibility of cross-contamination with
shrimp so if you look at the picture
though
it they're just obviously shrimp tails
they're it is not
physically possible to make cinnamon
sugar look
like these shrimp tails it is there's no
there is cinnamon sugar on the shrimp
tails but it's just very clearly shrimp
tales so then this
this guy responds and says okay well
after further investigation with my eyes
these are cinnamon-coated shrimp tails
you weirdos i wasn't all that mad until
you tried to gaslight me
then the cereal company offered him some
coupons for cereal and
the saga has been on pause there
this is not to go after cinnamon toast
crunch even for putting shellfish
in people's cereal that's unfortunate
but one suspects they didn't do that
intentionally
maybe some little rodent dragged them
into some cereal vat or something i
don't know
accidents happen uh it's a pretty gross
accident it's probably gonna have me
pausing on eating cinnamon
toast crunch for some time it's a good
cereal
but the real issue here is the gas
lighting
we've actually been talking about this
for several days now
the late conservative loss for roger
scrutin he said civilization
confession and forgiveness i need to be
able to say when i've done something
wrong and you need to be able to forgive
me
and i need to sacrifice my pride and you
need to sacrifice your resentment
and we both sacrifice something that we
cherish and then we move on
in our present culture you might call it
a cancel culture
you can't ever admit that you're wrong i
actually have some sympathy here for
cinnamon toast crunch because there is
no forgiveness in our culture anymore
so that the natural inclination here is
to say no that's not true it's not
whatever you're seeing it didn't happen
that is a culture
of gaslighting where we're not even
allowed to acknowledge basic truths
this is true in our politics more
broadly
if you say that a man is not a woman to
go back to this kind of most obvious
example
that is something that no one is allowed
to acknowledge in our culture anymore
we're not allowed to acknowledge
basic truths because of of the
implications they might
have we're all so on the defensive we
can't even call the shrimp tails in our
cereal
like we see them if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we have got the absolute top
content
out there